we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to oh I don't know what about
the 9 1 8 area code let's try that our
next caller from 9 1 8 what's your name
and where you're calling from dan from
Oklahoma what's on your mind today
hi Christian is I was wondering if you
have any family or close friends that
are conservative or you know Trump
supporters and if so do you get along
with them and like how do you deal with
that I don't really have any family
that's conservative I mean most of my
family is basically in I guess I guess
we would take three places it's mostly
in Argentina where it's people who are
on one wing of the left or another wing
of the left in Argentina there's there's
way fewer of what we would call actual
conservatives particularly in the
capital city of Buena siteís so it's
sort of like an internal left debate
that doesn't mean I mean the debates can
get pretty crazy because of what's been
Argentinian politics for the last 20
years but there's not really any
conservatives and then I've got family
members in a few in Israel who are very
liberal and then a few in France who are
also very liberal so no I don't really
have any conservative family members I
do however have some conservative
friends people that I've known for
longer periods of time and we basically
just don't talk about politics I mean I
think you pat have a much more sort of
in-your-face conservative element of
your family than I do many conservatives
of my family many Trump supporters in my
family laughs that was true during the
campaign maybe they've jumped ship now
that he's been president for a few
months of you aren't going so well you
know sometimes I engage in the debates
other times I just keep it to you know
snarky remarks like if Fox News is on
the television I'll be like oh there's
still people working there I thought
everyone either had to resign or quit
yeah and by the way Fox News now third
between MSNBC CNN and Fox for the first
time in I don't know I mean it couldn't
more than 15 years that they're now
lasting the among the big three Rachel
Maddow Show is now the top-rated cable
news show a heart because Bill O'Reilly
doesn't have his program yet more that's
true what about you I mean are you are
you debating politics with friends and
family
all the time um a lot of my friends
usually like I have some that to kind of
have an opinion and some that really
could care less I'm really doing the LSU
and then my friends that I'm yeah yeah
and then uh the friends that do usually
are kind of left side and don't like
Trump but yeah family it's kind of like
my mom's pretty liberal my dad is a
crazy crazy crazy like huge from
supporter and then I have like uncles
and cousins and conservative but that
come out is for me here's one thing I
would try okay and feel free if you if
you try this and then call back I've had
some success with it with people who
just are completely opposed on politics
but also they're kind of clueless so
they're kind of repeating talking points
they don't really understand take an
approach of don't try to argue or
present other facts merely ask questions
about how they came to the conclusions
that they came to okay so you can google
Socratic method of questioning and
lead into some of Peter big oceans work
and and some other folks and merely try
to ask questions which by their very
nature will get them to ultimately say
you know what I actually don't know and
and and try to take apart how they came
to their conclusions rather than give
opposing facts alright yeah anyway you
try it
report back I'm curious to hear how that
goes I've had some success with that
where I don't want to engage and I say
hey and how do you know that how did you
come across that and they say oh really
and and do you think that that's a good
way to evaluate of a or a or be
generally and this is this is actually
really good when people will throw out
like a racist or anti-semitic or
xenophobic thing a really good question
to say is interesting and what do you
think that says more broadly about X
group like I once had a situation where
some guy was telling me about some
Hasidic Jew in in New York City who he
observed driving in a particular way or
a particular type of car whatever and
the person was sort of framing it like
it's just an observation you know I'm
not right and I cut right through it by
saying that's really interesting that
you notice that what do you think that
is a reflection of more broadly about
these Hasidic Jews and at that point
this person had no question but to
either say you know what I think it
doesn't really mean anything it's just a
stupid anecdote or saying here is the
broader stereotype I hold about the
group very effective yeah I've seen you
employ the Peter Bogosian method even
with our live calls sometimes in our
interviews and it always creates some
interesting responses yeah you're going
to try that at next Thanksgiving maybe
Thanksgiving Memorial Day or let it be
the next title when you could get to
that right away all right that's it for
today we will be taking calls again next
week 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number but
not the only way to get your questions
on the show after the interview we'll be
doing next we will do audience questions
which you can always send in through our
website contact form at david pakman.com